foreign
[Music]
sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I am trying out
a brand new experiment and I would love
it if you came with me I'm going to
share with you my flow playlist so this
is actually an idea that I've had
floating around in the back of my head
now for quite some time
you know flow Arts has a very very close
relationship with music and uh you know
the music that I spin to is very
important to me
I sometimes get a little self-conscious
about that because the kind of music
that I listen to is not what I would
consider to be like common for flow
artists I really don't like EDM
um but I thought I would still share
with you all some of the music that is
inspiring me to move these days but
before we dive into that I want to go
ahead and give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys and Ultra POI for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible you
can learn more about all of these
amazing companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
that I have down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinski and Becca pekunen thank you so
very much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission so I clearly could
not have picked a better day for this it
is in the mid 40s here in DC and it is
extremely wet humidity I think is at
like 84 percent it is very very foggy as
I'm walking along I can just feel the
water droplets all over me
so good news is is that I have
my nice hoodie here that is going to do
a great job of keeping me warm uh but
I'm probably gonna have to look out for
my footing as I dance around here so my
theory for this video essentially works
like this I want to share with you all
five tracks that I've really been
enjoying for the past month and I want
you all to suggest a track for me that
you would like to see me do a flow
session for exclusively next Friday I'm
going to upload a flow video based upon
your requests and here's the thing is
your requests do not have to be just the
songs that I'm presenting in this video
here what I'm going to do is I'm going
to have you leave a comment with the
name of the song that you would like to
see me flow to next Friday and that will
be what I will do it could be one of
these five songs it could be something
else basically whichever song gets the
most comments that's the one I'm flowing
out to so once again I want you to leave
a comment with the name of the song that
you would like to see me flow out to
next Friday and I'm will do a single
take video where I flow out and it will
be unrehearsed unplanned it'll just be
me letting loose in a way that is more
informal than the usual flow videos that
I have that I upload cool so how about
we dive into my playlist then yeah
see if I'm going to need to move the
camera a little bit I am definitely
going to have to move the camera a
little bit
there we go cool set up my speaker all
right so the first track I'm gonna play
for you all
is Saturday Night by Honey which
um you know it's it's kind of an upbeat
poppy track and it just it has this
interesting bridge to it that reminds me
a little bit of Somebody That I Used to
Know by Gautier in that it's uh
basically a guy talking about wanting uh
a girl to give him a call on a Saturday
night and being upset that she didn't
and her being absolutely baffled that
this was something that he was expecting
from her
[Applause]
[Music]
right
cool our next one is called the black
it's by VHS collection they are a synth
pop group that's out of New York and uh
yeah there's just something about the
hook and the chorus about like kind of
acknowledging one's inner darkness that
uh that kind of pops out to me and also
I just think that the kind of synth
washes in this one are pretty cool so
let's see if you like it too
[Music]
relax
ing
uh
all right so next up we have Mona Lisa
by little daylight and again I just
really like the hook in it
um I think part of it is just like I dig
the texture of the lead singer's voice
and I really like the lyrical hook about
smiling
[Music]
you're into it
cool so the next song Here is called Top
by Hooch and this is actually a song
that has been suggested to me many many
many times in the past few months by uh
my Apple music uh suggested playlist
um and I finally got around to just
sticking it on a playlist because I knew
that I liked it but I never had like a
place for it to live uh until now and I
think I'm also going to switch over to
some Led poi
I'm shaking my body
foreign
[Music]
Disaster by dreamers uh dreamers is one
of those bands that I picked up a bunch
of their songs uh on my uh iTunes
playlist
I don't know how I missed this one
before but uh yeah I just really like
the really crunchy guitars in the chorus
and uh yeah let's see uh see how it
moves me today
California's at the corner store to take
to bed
tell me that you need me on the floor
ask me what the hell I'm looking for
like you don't know
all right friends well I think I'm gonna
head back in because it is quite moist
out but uh again
make sure to leave down in the comments
which one of these tracks is your
favorites and quite frankly if any of
them didn't stick out to you then you
can leave the name of any other track
down below and whichever track gets the
most comments that's the one that I'm
going to do a one take flow video for
next Friday so let me know what you want
to hear and let me know is this a
formatted video that you dig do you like
knowing what I'm listening to and do you
like having the capacity to make a
request for a song for me to flow to let
me know down in the comments in the
meantime make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to help other people find
this video and of course to help my
channel grow
[Music]
foreign
this video would not be possible without
the kind of support of all of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon and they
along with the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support and if you out there
watching would like to become a
supporter and are not currently you can
do so by heading on over to patreon.com
directs factorpoi and signing up there
you can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to The Wider
world so go check that out please and
thank you all right it's time for me to
go get dry thank you all so much for
watching if you are interested in
watching some of my other flow videos
I'm going to leave a link to a playlist
of such videos down in the description
as well as up on screen if you are
watching on YouTube also if you're
watching on YouTube the algorithm thinks
that you might like this top video based
upon your past viewing habits so maybe
give that a look as well thanks so much
make sure to get outside and flow today
I hope it is drier wherever you happen
to be and I'll see you with a new video
real soon
peace